welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 9
and we're going to learn how
billionaires get and stay
motivated enjoy
[Music]
when i started amazon it was 25 years
ago
i started amazon in 1994.
when i went to see investors the first
question i had to answer
is what is the internet none of my
investors had ever heard of the internet
and the
the the the the idea that i had in mind
was to build a bookstore i realized that
we could build a store
which would have every book ever printed
in any language in print or out of print
and we could do that online it would be
impossible in a physical store and that
was the founding idea of amazon
and but did i expect what would happen
today no you know we started
uh i've been at amazon when it was one
person
me when it was 10 people when it was a
hundred people when it was a thousand
people
and today when it's you know more than
seven hundred thousand people and
approaching seventy
thousand people just here in india so
no i did not predict that and actually i
think if anybody had predicted that they
would have needed to be immediately
institutionalized in a mental facility
because it's not a normal thing to have
happen
my dream when i started amazon was that
one day we might be able to afford a
forklift
so it's been a very uh
fun journey for me and by the way i
still tap dance into work
i'm having so much fun what propelled
you to sell things more than books
after books we started selling music and
then we started selling
videos and then i got smart and i um i
emailed
a thousand randomly selected customers
and asked them besides the things we saw
today what would you like to see us sell
and that answer came back incredibly
long tailed the way they answered the
question
was with whatever they were looking for
at that moment so like i remember one of
the answers was
i wish you sold windshield wiper blades
because i really need windshield wiper
blades
and i thought to myself we can sell
anything this way
and and then so then we launched
electronics and toys
and many other categories over time and
the division became because you read the
original business plan it's just
books how would you advise people who
aren't necessarily going into a
career field in which you would make a
large base salary such as like
medicine or something like that maybe
performing arts or music how would you
advise us to
keep up financially with the rest of the
world
well it there it is true that a market
system
uh does not pay as well in some
in some activities as as
might seem appropriate for the
importance of those activities the
society
just take teaching for example i mean
teaching does not pay well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as
as interested in who you're the teachers
of your children are
as who your accountant is or you know
whatever or who's winning the
heavyweight title of the world or that
sort of thing but
but it doesn't it doesn't pay well and
and
it's a fundamental choice uh whether
you're going to go into something
for many people it'd be it'd be a
fundamental choice whether you're going
to go into something you love or
something
to try and make a lot of money i think
that generally it pays to go with what
you love
i think that it's very hard to find
people
when they get to be my age who say
they're on that they've loved what
they've done all their life and feel was
very worthwhile
uh but they're terribly sad they made
that choice because they didn't make a
lot of money i
i don't think anybody's ever ever said
that to me that they wish they'd gone
into something else where they
were uncomfortable doing it or didn't
enjoy it didn't feel very productive but
made a lot of money
so i don't i don't think you'll find
that so i would i would i would go to
work
i would go to work in whatever turns you
on
it may turn out that it'll it'll be more
profitable than than you can think but
almost everybody here will make enough
money unless they get some terrible
habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is is uh is pretty darn good i
mean
it is it's not necessary to have
uh huge amounts of money in order to
enjoy yourself i enjoyed myself when i
was
at my ten thousand dollars and i live in
the same house that i lived in when i
was making it when i had about that i
bought it 41 years ago
i like the house then i like the house
now i mean
if you think about it if you have a
reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating mcdonald's so we're we're to
push
on on on food i mean you know in fact i
hope it's dairy queen actually in may
and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order
we both can afford it uh you know you'll
you'll wear the same clothes i wear i'll
pay more for my suits but as soon as i
put them on they look cheap on me so
we'll look about the same and uh
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's it's warm in
winter and it's cool in summer and it's
comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and and
what difference does it make if you have
50 more rooms or you know guest houses
or all that
you know it'll probably just bring you
problems i mean you have to worry about
the
about the greenskeeper or something when
you get through so i
i i have been in the houses of people uh
where the houses are worth
oh probably 200 times uh what my house
is worth and
i would not be any happier in those
houses at all in fact i'd be less happy
i just have one more thing to
to worry about and you know the dozens
of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah
uh we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you'll probably drive a
better car
i drive a car's about eight years old i
don't know what it's worth now but it
gets me around fine
i mean i'm perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll work on the same computer pretty
much the only difference will be
how we travel long distances you know i
will
fly in a plane that's more comfortable
than
than flying southwest airlines or
something which i've got nothing against
but
that's the one real big difference and
other than that i do what i like every
day i hope you
you'll do what you like every day to do
and i work with nice people i hope you
work with nice people
uh and there's 24 hours in the day and
those are
where the hours go so great wealth
uh is the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and and to trade
a decent income and something you love
doing and something where you feel
worthwhile doing it
for huge wealth where you
trade off a lot of your principles uh
would be a terrible mistake
you're lucky in life if you can find
your passion i tell the students you
know what
you may have to take a job or two you
get you got to eat
but never give up searching for the job
that's your passion
try to find the job that you would have
if you were independently rich
that's the job i have and when you find
that job the job that causes you
to be excited every day and forget about
the pay
and where you associate with people you
love doing what you love it doesn't get
any better than that
my partner charlie is 89 and we were
talking about that this weekend you know
i'm 82 he's 89.
we do what we love every day with people
we love you know and they seem to like
us okay so
you know it how can it be any better and
just
cost of living does not equate the
standard of living and the standard of
living is you know
achieving what you want to achieve
working with people that you love and
you don't need that much money aside i
love to ride around in a private plate i
will
totally acknowledge that leave it
leaving that out you know i basically
you know leaving out taxes and charity
and things like that i could live on
easily live 100 000
a year and it and i wouldn't live i
wouldn't live
better if i had eight houses if i hadn't
you know a 400-foot yacht or anything of
the sword
i've been on 400 foot yachts and i've
been a lot of fancy houses
but i'm in a house that i bought 55
years ago
it's warm in the winter it's cool in the
summer
it has everything i wanted plus it has
all kinds of good memories you know
my kids have good thoughts about it i
can't imagine
living any better i paid thirty one
thousand five hundred dollars for it i
could pay 31 million
for a house and and it wouldn't it
wouldn't do for me what this present
house does
i was wondering how you define success
personally
well i i can certainly define happiness
because that's what that's what i am
i mean i i and if that
i mean i get to do what i like to do
every single day of the year and i get
to do it with people i like and i get to
the i get to
i don't have to associate with anybody
causes my stomach to churn
and uh the only thing in my job i don't
like and this only happens about every
three or four years
occasionally i have to fire somebody and
i don't like that's the only thing
other than i tap dance to work and i get
down there and i think i'm supposed to
lie on my back and paint the ceiling you
know or something like microwaves i mean
that's the way i feel and and it it
doesn't diminish
it it's it's tremendous fun so uh
you know if uh uh they say that uh
uh success is uh uh uh getting what you
want and happiness is wanting what you
get
well i don't know which one applies in
this case but i
i do know that i i wouldn't be doing
anything else i mean
uh i do advise you you know and when you
go out to work go go to work for an
organization that you admire
people you admire because it'll it'll
it'll turn you on and and
uh you ought to be happy where you are
working and
i always worry about people who say you
know i'm going to do this for 10 years i
really don't like it very well then i'll
do 10 more years of this
i mean that's a little like saving up
sex for your old age i mean
not a very good idea
so get right in you got to recommend
that get ready get right into it
get right into what you enjoy you know
and and
and you'll be successful at it you
really will i mean you won't be able to
miss
and uh um you know that's uh
uh i don't regard what i do as the most
important thing in the world at all but
it's right for me i mean i happen to be
wired in a certain way that what i do
works in this if i had to do what
you know bill does i mean it lasts about
10 minutes
and that's true of a lot of things but i
luckily i kind of stumbled into the
thing that i
i do best and and that you know that
it's worked out well
things that i've chosen have not been um
i've not been trying to optimize on a
risk-adjusted return basis
so there are uh like i would not
say that i went into the rocket business
the car business
uh or the solar business thinking that
it's a it's a great opportunity
i just thought that that something
needed to be done
in in these industries in order to make
a difference
and that's why i did it so um
but in general i do think it's worth
thinking about like
what you whether what you're doing is
going to result in disruptive change or
not
if it's just incremental it's unlikely
to
to be something major it's got to be
something that's substantially better
than
what's going on before other car
companies just really want to outsource
battery
technology not know even not even making
the
like this battery module and sell but
they're they're obviously outsourcing
the cells but even outsourcing the
modules in the packs
you know and it's like they're really
not thinking about fundamental
chemistry improvements and it is
so i i should say a bit about like like
electric vehicles and
and and so or sustainable energy in
general you know i said it was
it was pretty i think obvious to not not
just me to move it to a lot of people
may even go back 30 years or longer that
we must have uh a sustainable energy
solution
in fact it's it's total logical if it's
if it's
if it's not sustainable we must at some
point
find an alternative to it and so even if
there were no
environmental impact to uh the sort of
fossil fuel economy
then we would run out of them and then
we'd have economic collapse and
civilization would fall apart so so that
that was actually my initial motivation
for
electric vehicles is like okay we've got
to have a solution that does not
require um mining hydrocarbons
uh that that that is sustainable in the
long term
it was not actually initially from an
environmental standpoint because i had
not
realized the gravity of the
environmental situation at that time
um and i thought actually for sure by
now we'd have electric cars
we just sold a company out of atlanta um
that
went on shark tank a cycloramic they had
the
the um iphone that used the buzzer and
you
ran this app on it and it just turned
around and did a panoramic version of
the phone of took panoramic pictures
well they changed the format of the
iphone which is great this is a great
lesson for entrepreneurs
right so this guy came in with this
really cool app work with an iphone 5
and it just turned around and take
panoramic pictures
and then stitch them together and it was
a cool picture
well not so i give them 250 000 i think
for
20 of the company or 25 of the company
not four months later apple changes the
iphone
and it's got this like rounded thing
underneath and we're like oh what's what
are we gonna do but
the guy was smart and one of the things
i always look for
for companies coming in is what's your
unique advantage
what is the one thing you have that
differentiates you from other companies
and for this guy the product was
interesting
but you know as i said on the show the
ability to
to program video and use what became
computer vision
was a unique skill that was hard to find
and so we worked with him and actually
brought it worked with him to bring in
another ceo
and they used that same technology to be
able to scan cars so now if you go to
websites like carvana to buy a car and
you see how you can turn the car around
just right there
that started with their software and the
guy's name was bruno so bruno we just
sold his company for 22 and a half
million dollars a couple weeks ago and
so i walked away with
you know 25 of that so i was like yeah
shark tank
throughout my 20s i continued
experimenting
trying different things racing bikes and
boats and constantly changing jobs
it didn't take me long to discover that
the most interesting and rewarding
programming jobs
were found at a cluster of companies
located south of stanford university in
north of san jose
silicon valley was in its infancy
i was still in my twenties when i went
to work for my first
silicon valley startup amdahl
where we developed the world's fastest
mainframe computer
faster than anything ibm had next stop
was ampex
where we built the world's largest
digital data storage system
then on to precision instruments where
we built an
even larger data storage system this
time using lasers
i was the vice president in charge of
software development
it was all very cutting edge and
challenging and cool
i liked my work most of the time but i
didn't love it
i searched and i searched but i just
could not find a software engineering
job
that i loved as much as i loved sailing
so i tried to create one
i put together a plan to start my own
company
that way i could completely control my
work environment
i would hire the most talented
programmers i knew
and we would all work together on the
most
interesting and challenging software
projects
my group my goal was to create the
perfect job
for me a job i truly loved
i never ex i never expected the company
to grow beyond 50 people
how did you get through like tactically
to a sale in the encyclopedia world like
people don't want to hear from you so
like how do you overcome that
what a question asked me the average
encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days i was at it for three
and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is
you went for an interview they told you
all you could possibly make
off commission only and we were in
training for three days it was a
presentation that was scripted
we'd have to memorize the whole thing
when you got in the field you remember
parts of it
you knock on doors you're not quite sure
of yourself a lot of dirts are close in
your face
but what happens after a while you start
getting used to it and you see what you
can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other
salespeople what you see what you do
what did i say
so let's say knock on 100 door skin into
one give 10 presentations to sell one
book
but then when you get better and better
at it through your experiences and
losses along the way
it sharpens you up where all of a sudden
i got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than
one order commission only but i believe
that i could do that i believe that
colleges were the best set of books
because a high school student could read
it it wasn't like a college manual you
had to read
and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe
that what you're doing is good is going
to benefit somebody and you learn as you
go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people don't know these things
look someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye
because you feel uncomfortable of course
you do they're not on the same
wavelength you're under the same
frequency so what do you do how do you
overcome that
you learn these things along the way you
look them right between the eyes or
their eyebrows looks like you're looking
over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh
there's all these things and of course
smile smile is the most wonderful thing
god gave us
and you don't smile when you first talk
to somebody you smile before you knock
on their
door and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes
people change by the time i was 31 i'd
lost 11 different people close to me
from separate tragedies oh my gosh
yeah so i've been you know dropped to my
knees many times in life by grief i mean
just
it's like unbearably painful but i will
say that
you know going through that i always
think there's a hidden blessing in
everything that we go through in life
and
one of the blessings was that facing my
own mortality at a really young age
had all these hidden gifts you know
i use mortality and sort of the
insignificance of all of this
in a positive way you know it doesn't
you know
just how temporary this all is to
fuel me and to say why would i ever
not do this what because i'm afraid that
person that person's not going to
remember me five minutes after i make a
fool of myself anyway like
let's do this we're all here for just a
short period of time so
it freed me up um in a way that i think
most people in the natural course of
life you know maybe
starts to think about in their 40s when
they might lose
a parent or a grandparent or something
so yeah
really how do you get through a
challenging loss like that like
what's your process oh my gosh i one day
at a time
i mean it is just one day at a time it
looks like um you always go out of your
comfort zone
right coming onto an island that was
completely deserted
no fresh water you didn't even have the
money to buy it and
now you're sleeping on a tent on the
beach trying to figure out how to get
fresh water here you do that often you
did it with the airline
i mean i was just somebody that
experienced the bad experience of
traveling on
airlines i was actually trying to get to
the bvi
the british virgin islands one day from
puerto rico and the same lovely lady was
waiting for me and i'd been away for
three weeks and
american airlines bumped the flight and
uh and so i went to the back of the
airport i hired a plane
um i hired a blackboard
i wrote um virgin airlines uh
one way 29 to the bvi went around all
the people had been bumped and i filled
my first
plane and and that got me thinking you
know that airlines do bump people they
don't
care about you or me particularly in the
air and so we
um so i then rang up boeing and said you
have any secondhand seven four seven
okay i mean it was literally that you
just sat in the airport and said i'm
starting an airline right now because
i'm frustrated
exactly and i think most most of the
best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration i think you know if you're
if you're um frustrated about something
um the best way of
sorting it out is get out and do it and
you've got yourself a business
for 25 i recommitted to my education but
this time i started studying not things
that were in books but people that it
actually created wealth not people that
had made
money but people that had created wealth
this is completely different
i was no longer studying accounting and
economics i was studying
wealthy people and only wealthy people
i'm not talking about the doctor that
was a neighbor
that makes a million dollars a year and
he's working 18 hours a day and he hates
his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with family i'm
talking about the yacht people
i'm talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation
i'm talking about the car dealer that
had uh 28 car dealerships
or 82 car dealerships that has
indisposable money i'm talking about the
walton money we're talking about with
the waltons last week
increased their net worth by 11 billion
dollars and they haven't worked for 30
years
that's the kind of wealth i started
studying i started reading barons in a
wall street journal
and i quickly realized something that
the wealthy people
had financial freedom and no one else
did okay
a very small percentage of people lots
of people have money
my uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money
wouldn't spend it acted like a miser
buried money in the backyard
i realized my parents had it wrong the
information i had that was wrong
and this is the number one thing i want
you to get out of tonight
the information you have is wrong
the wealthy talk differently than the
middle class
i watched my mom and my dad i started
comparing the wealthy people
to what my dad did my dad worked every
day every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office
he was working in the yard they saved
money they cut their own grass
okay we ate all our food we turned the
lights off we didn't waste anything
and that was uncertainty it was
insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated
uncertainty insecurity and fear and and
all the lessons about money money
doesn't grow on trees a penny saved is a
penny earned
eat all your food people are starving
okay money
money you don't waste it don't play with
it all that
creates insecurity and it's incorrect
they say your network equals your net
worth
your ability to move this planet to
change
things to get investors funding money
is determined by who you know if you've
got a money problem i guarantee it's got
something to do with your network
okay if you if you're having marriage
problems i assure you
with 100 certainty if you're having
marriage problems there's somebody in
your network
that believes in marriage problems if
you're having kidney problems
you know not kitty kitty now i'm talking
about if you got problems with your kids
it's because your network is having
problems with chilling
if you have a time problem i don't have
enough time i can't find enough time i'm
working too hard i never have time i
can't find time to work out i can't find
time for the kids i can't find time for
the marriage
you have a network of people that have
time
problems this is um at the beverly hills
hotel today
if you've never stayed here you have to
okay every single day that i have been
here i have met someone
that will help me in my career i can't
they don't tell you this in school they
don't teach you this your parents didn't
teach you this you have to go where the
money is
money is not just okay i'm gonna buy a
lamborghini and i'm gonna buy a big
house and i'm gonna buy some jewelry and
i'm gonna get some nice sunglasses
i'm gonna go buy a big watch and i'm
gonna go on vacation it's about going
where
other people are that have money and
that can help you
that can help you so you can help others
so you can help your parents so you can
take care of them
so you can take care of your kids so you
could be a good example look money's not
going to make you happy you guys already
know that
everybody knows that i don't even know
what we're talking about money will not
make you happy
but
it'll get you an uber it'll get you an
uber it'll get you a hotel room it'll
get you access to the polo lounge
it'll get you breakfast this morning to
sit at the right place with the right
people
that maybe someone someone discovers
what you're doing what you're up to
and that takes interest every single
breakfast
every single lunch that i've been here
and every single dinner
that i've been sitting out in public i
have met someone that can literally help
me with my career
we started a two-day trip here that's
turned into
five days here in la okay now i'm not
saying you need to go to l.a
to meet people but one thing you got to
go out to you need to spend your money
use money
use money use money
otherwise it's useless okay quick quick
quit uh degrading money quit thinking
money's at root of all evil quit
thinking money's a bad thing it's not do
you need money to create opportunities
for yourself to get known in the world
the people that operate this planet the
handful the one percenters
have different information than you have
[Music]
okay they're not talking about going to
college they're not talking about saving
money
[Music]
you don't hear wealthy people talking
about i need to buy a house
[Music]
warren buffett you know warren buffett
warren buffett is not like
i need to buy a house i have to have a
home to live in
warren buffett bought one house his
whole life he never talks about it
what's he buying he's buying
businesses what's he investing his money
in businesses
right he's not buying a house where
money dies
first 35 40 years of my life i was being
held back by what i knew
what i thought was the truth it wasn't
the truth these people and companies
that are buying private jets
that are hooking up with whoever they
want when they want that are spending
millions and millions and millions of
dollars on connections
and speed and access
dude what are they doing man what are
they doing okay
they're doing something different than
you and i were taught to do the school
systems don't teach you this your mama
didn't teach you this your daddy didn't
teach you this
your family doesn't know this right so
you got to go outside your circle of
influence
and look around
12 14 million 6 million
4 million
and a little guy a little guy right here
got the big jet on the tarmac
how's a little guy like me end up making
it all the way up to food shape
because i studied those guys
you can do the same thing if you study
hard enough the right people
not those guys those are the pilots okay
see they work for 150 grand a year i
think they're they're
they're cutting a big fat hog in the ass
oh i make 175
000 but they stopped learning what the
owner knows
okay study man study paid the price
for the information and then pay for the
price of
access to the people and learn from them
if you study the most successful people
that you know
in any business the warren buffets in
finance
the lebron james and basketball you just
start studying i've been studying since
i was
since my dad died my dad died when i was
10 years old and i needed
mentors and you can't go get another dad
my uncles they weren't they had their
own life going on so they they couldn't
mentor me
so i was like well who are these people
we we all have examples
the problem today in america is the
example
it's getting more and more average it's
we're becoming an epidemic of mediocrity
so
if you study the really really you know
exuberantly successful people
they're going to have some traits in
common obsessed
if you've ever met a great sales manager
great sales person
great used car manager great finance
manager they're obsessed
they read study learn eat it you know
they're obsessed people
see obsession in our culture though is
not a good thing
if you when you hear the word obsession
you start thinking a guy's got a problem
obsessive compulsive disorder look if
you're not getting labeled
if people are not labeling you in
society as a freak case
then you're not successful whatever goal
you want let's say you have a financial
goal even though that's just one goal
you know you'd have life spiritual your
family
your marriage how much action do you
need to take
every time i'm having trouble every time
i'm like man i don't think i can get to
where i'm going
i just start looking at the top i don't
look at the bad facts all i do is i
start searching
tell me about wealthy people facts about
wealthy people anything what are they
doing what are they buying it just gets
me out of my problem right
it gets me to think bigger you know the
the first plane i bought i bought this
plane because i saw other wealthy people
making moves i'm not an irresponsible
person okay
like i have always been a very frugal
person but the frugal was hurting me
not helping me i don't think that people
burn out
i think it's impossible i'm not i'm not
a piece of wax i'm not a candle
so the burnout thing was put on us by
people that quit already yeah you're
going to burn out dude you're going to
burn
out burnout is never about work nobody
burns out because they work too hard
oh you're burning the candle at both
ends i'm a spiritual being i create
energy this is a
irresponsibility like i've never met a
human being that was made of wax
you know oh yeah but you know i'm
burning at both ends you're
you're a being you're a being okay like
quit saying something's happening to you
this goes back to cause and effect
i create energy and i love your example
of the kids
okay that kid can play that game it's
always a game though yeah oh dio not
it's always a game
there's nothing that entertains people
more than a game
and so when i was uh 18 years old man i
was playing a game called asteroids i
would play
i would play 80 of it a day because it
cost a quarter every game right and i'm
just piling
throwing them in doing anything i can to
get quarters so i can dump them into
this
into this game and i was trying to get
to the next level look at how people
play candy crush
700 levels and they're still looking for
the next level over and over
it's games and that energy doesn't run
out until you hit boredom
because you can see a kid play a game
too long and then
they start getting like kind of smashed
in and their attitude gets bad
because they've been playing that same
game too long yeah so i know that as
long as i'm interested
not for me not passionate for me
well for me for me i need to be able to
win at a game
if there's a chance i can win i'll be
excited about the game
if there's no chance to win i have no
interest
so for me for me the idea that i'm going
to follow my passions
is a little bit deluded for me i i think
people are looking for their passion i
would not follow my passion i would
i would follow the wins right so are you
saying there's things that you can
really enjoy but you don't think you
could win is that what you mean i
i think if if yeah i think that if
you're
if there's no victory the passion is
is a little bit um
narcissistic like oh i'm gonna i'm meant
to be a
artist maybe ain't nobody buying your
art
nobody's buying it all you're doing
stacking art okay who is so selfish
i do this for me it makes me feel good
seven billion people on this planet man
like if you keep all this to yourself
sooner or later around you
and at some point you're going to see
this person cave in in depression
and and it's like like where's the
where's where where do you get the art
out
like you know like i love watches right
mostly
so do i yeah most of my watches end up
on somebody else's arm
yeah like i like i have it for a while i
love it for a while and then i'm like
here you have it
yeah and so for me like it needs to get
out
and and um i have a victory in that
yeah i see it on somebody else's arm it
makes me happy yeah
and and so if if i write a book and the
book doesn't get sold
i'm not going to be excited about that
book i need the book in hands of other
people
if you want to build a network number
one thing commit to building a network
a network by definition is not if you're
building a new
network it's not the people you're
already with
it's how do i add people to my network
so number one you got to commit to
building a network number two
who do you want in the network
who is it most of you just go for more
people like you have already in your
network
i want new people new characters
new personalities new thinking new ideas
the old adage if you're the smartest
person in the room
you in the wrong room
and number three when you start building
this network up and you start meeting
the people
okay number two is who do you want to
meet who who are you going to add to the
network you go nine thousand people in a
room you don't need to meet all nine
thousand you need to meet maybe a list
of
30 or 40 people who do you want to meet
number three
when you meet them focus on them not on
you
it shouldn't be here's my card i'm a
chiropractor this is what i do
uh can i give you an adjustment dude it
should be like
who are you how can i help you what are
you doing where do you
live okay what projects are you working
on
how can i help you because i started
studying people
that did more not people that
didn't do more not people that said do
less not people that said hey don't be
satisfied
or be satisfied not people that said hey
be grateful for what you have
i started studying people that said
and had done more that you can do more
that's who i listen to today i listen to
the people my friends in my life the
people i listen to the people i talk to
the people that i follow on facebook or
or or youtube or instagram i don't
follow everybody
i follow the people that say you can do
more dude i follow the people that say
i am doing more i follow the people that
are
actually doing something on this planet
to make a difference for the better
you have to be selective you have to
give something up okay you cannot listen
to everybody
to every voice to every person is quit
or given up
you got to make a decision if you have
that little voice inside of you that
says you can do more you have to
to give attention to that voice
and you got to feed it with those
that support that idea that you can do
more
25 years old drug problem broke
literally i had more debt than i had
money had no money
so that was easy didn't have any
direction
no guidance no mentors no connections
really no clue i just had that one
little thing that one little thing was
going on for me
you can do more man it haunted me
constantly
so if you have that little thing okay
and i know you do
listen to it right now listen just
listen
does this say hey you could do a little
more
my friend lewis house says he had that
voice damon john says
i had that voice ed milette says i had
that voice
okay the tim's story grant i have that
voice i had it i have it now
i can do more i know you can do more
elena my wife she's all we had had that
voice in her she wanted to be a star in
hollywood
right so we all have dreams you have
dreams
and with those dreams come barriers
obstacles difficulties setbacks
that's going to come and if you could
keep surrounding yourself with people
that say
hey the barriers are going to win the
obstacle obstacles are going to win
nobody really ever makes it you know
it's all [ __ ]
you don't need all that just be grateful
for what you have settle for what you
have take whatever you got
then you're going to quit and you're
going to give up okay i don't want you
to give up
you might be the next superstar of this
universe you might be the next great
example for other people what they can
do
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag billionaire mindset in the
comments below
so i can celebrate you so in terms of
making decisions you want to do things
that will serve other people
serving others is hardwired into us they
did fmri scans of the brain
and when you help other people it hits
the same part of your brain as food and
sex
more than receiving more than getting
gifts is helping others serving others
being of
use you want to wake up every day and
feel like the work you do matters that
you're having an impact we all want to
go off and
have an impact you are built to serve
and so already in your decision making
does it serve somebody else does it help
other people in some way
if it's yes you're making progress in
the book i go through a three-step
process
who i how so who your one word most
important core value
what do you stand for who are you you
have one word that is more important
than all the others so
believe is my most important core value
and so already
the decisions that i make are through
the lens of belief this video is about
believe i hope it's my intention i may
not always
execute on it as best as i can but it's
always my intention and so if you
understand what your one word is
then it allows you to make your decision
making process
a lot cleaner a lot simpler a lot easier
next is your why your purpose comes from
your pain
your why comes from your pain the thing
that you want to help and serve other
people with
the problem that you want to solve is
the same problem that you went through
the people who you will love serving are
the people who are currently struggling
with the thing that you
struggled with your purpose comes from
your pain and so whatever was the most
painful moment in your life the moment
where you felt
the lowest the worst the most worthless
as a human being
your purpose for the rest of your life
is to help other people who currently
feel that way so think about who you
used to be who you were five years ago
whenever you were struggling the most
there's lots of people who currently are
like you used to be you want to go serve
them and then the how becomes
how did you get through it how did you
get out of that problem you may not even
be fully out of the problem
whatever you struggled and suffered with
you're not done you're still growing
you're still learning you're still
improving
you're still climbing that staircase you
know of knowledge and growth
but every time you take a step up on the
staircase you can reach back and pull
somebody else up one more step
one more step the more you learn and
grow the more you can pull people up
with you
and so however you got out of the hole
even though you're not done
you're better than you used to be
there's lots of people who currently are
who you used to be
and so however you got out becomes a
recipe to teach other people as well
and so that's the first part you're
built to serve you go through the who
why how process
and you can figure out with a lot more
clarity the decisions that you need to
take in your life
number two is understanding that you
want to make big decisions in your life
with your heart and the small ones with
your head
big decisions with the heart small ones
with the head don't make a list
people take out a paper and they make a
list of persons don't do that
don't make big decisions logically
because the big things that you want in
life
come from creating a new world that
doesn't exist you're trying to create a
masterpiece of a life that does not
exist for anybody else
your life will be a masterpiece that
nobody has created yet
that is something that your brain can
understand your brain is logical
logic can't understand creating
something new because that's art
that's passion that's heart your heart
can create something new
your brain understands something that
currently exists and so your heart has
to make the big decisions
don't make big decisions through logic
you make big decisions to the things
that you love doing it's why
following your passion is the number one
piece of advice consistently across all
high achievers
successful entrepreneurs innovators
leaders they all say it
you have to follow your passion you have
to find a thing that you love doing
because that's going to carry you to
create something that's never been
created before
and so whenever you're deciding to do
something get your head out of the
equation
it's not about logic it's what do you
love doing what do you badly want to do
what would fill you up big decisions
with the heart small ones with your head
so you use your heart to decide what you
want to do and then you use your head to
figure out how to do it
at the very beginning chances are your
head and your heart are against each
other your heart wants to do this your
head says you can't do that
you didn't go to school you're not
capable of that are you nuts you can't
do that stay here stay safe this is
where you should be
your heart says no i want to do this
crazy thing
you decide with the heart and then your
head has to come on board
when you say i am doing this then your
brain says okay well
she's serious so let's figure out how to
do it right i'm going to help use my
head now to figure out how to go off and
create this thing
because my heart's demanded big
decisions with the heart smalls with the
head
and step number three is trust your
ideas and act
trust that the ideas that come to you an
idea probably came to you today
whatever idea flow through you trust
that it is flowing through you that it
came to you for a reason
that you are a genius that you have
great ideas
and that you are not born to sit here
come up with great ideas and do nothing
about them
trust your ideas we don't trust our
ideas enough we don't trust ourselves
enough that idea
was given to you for a reason you have
to go do something about it
and act even though it doesn't make
sense even though people may judge you
even though it's probably not going to
work out the first time you go off and
do it right
trust your ideas teach yourself that as
soon as you get an idea
that that's the right thing for you
trust that's the right thing for you
right now if i'm thinking about whatever
sushi
then sushi is the right thing for me and
i'm going to eat sushi tonight
[Music]
it may sound crazy that's how you need
to start making decisions you need to
start listening to your intuition more
right listening to your heart listening
to your gut more
than trying to just follow simple logic
in your head some people are built to
serve the world some people want to have
a giant mission a giant vision you want
to impact the lives of millions of
people
that's me that may be you if you're
watching this that's most entrepreneurs
i think you have a giant vision
and you want to change the world but
some people are built to serve
the 25 closest people to them if i look
at my wife nina as an example
she doesn't have a giant mission she
doesn't have a giant vision
but she still wants to serve if you're
not happy
if you're not happy in life it's because
you're not serving
you're not serving deeply enough to the
people who you care most about
or you're not serving broadly enough to
have a big enough impact
on the people around you your community
your country
your continent the world right so
entrepreneurs are default too i think we
want to serve the world
they did functional mris on the brain
functional mris
and they studied the impact of serving
of helping other people
and it showed that when you serve other
people when you get the satisfaction you
help somebody else out
it touches the same part of your brain
as eating food and having sex which are
both also pretty important things in
life i think you would agree
and so you're built to serve and and
they went deeper into the study and they
found that
giving triggers it more than receiving
so all of the stories that we know of
how giving is great and santa claus
and you know it's better to give than to
receive and all this stuff right the
things that we've been told
in our stories that have been handed
down to us is backed up by science
it's backed up by science so if you're
not happy right now
if you're a little bit low right now the
easiest path
out is service serve go help people if
you woke up every day
and felt like the work that you didn't
matter to somebody either to again
the closest people to you like my wife
who's still in touch with their friends
from kindergarten in china
to someone like me who wants to have a
giant impact and reach
a billion people around the world if
you're not happy
all you have to do is start to serve so
then it becomes a question of well how
do you serve how do you either build
your vision or find a vision
well it comes from whatever you
struggled with right the thing that you
struggled with the most your purpose
comes from your pain
and this is what i outlined in my book
built to serve check it out build a
serve there's a link in the description
go check it out support me
because it's a super important book that
i think is going to really help a lot of
people
including you your purpose comes from
your pain whatever you struggle the most
with is the thing you want to help other
people with for life so
serving the world or serving the closest
people to you can take on many forms
and you'll love helping people just
because that's how we're wired as
people but who specifically do you want
to help and how
makes a difference holding the door for
somebody
down here right like if somebody's gonna
somebody was crossing
the rocks there's this rocky part over
here on the beach way down there in the
corner this really rocky area
and if i helped somebody cross right
this
was an older couple that couldn't get
across so we went first and helped them
across
helping that makes me feel good right
because it's serving others
but it's not as deep that level of
service
is surface level it's still fantastic
it's great it makes you feel good
you can check off good deep for the day
but it's not as good
as helping an entrepreneur because i
struggled so much as an entrepreneur is
the most painful moment in my life is
putting on my business
and i know what it's like and i want to
make the practice a little bit easier
for other people
so helping random stranger is still good
better than not
but helping an entrepreneur fills me up
to a level that
that is on the level of my soul and so
you need to find the same thing for you
whatever you felt the most worthless as
a human being you struggled the most
as a person you felt worthless you felt
disposable as a person
that feeling that emotional feeling you
want to help other people not feel the
same way
and no no no no that there are
so many people there are so many people
who currently are
what you used to be there are so many
people who currently feel
the same way that you used to feel and
your purpose is to help those people
forever that will never get old i love
helping entrepreneurs when i'm 95.
i struggled the lowest point in my life
as an entrepreneur as a human
was when i was 19 and i quit on my
business partner
and i felt worthless and now i'm 39 i'm
almost 40 in may i turn 40.
and it doesn't get old two decades later
i'm still loving it
helping entrepreneurs how you do it
changes it's youtube now it'll be
holograms in 10 years it'll be vr
right you'll watch me through your
goggles or i'll be beaming into your
living room
it's going to change with time but the
purpose the mission the vision doesn't
change i want to solve the world's
biggest problem
people don't believe in themselves
enough and so it starts with the
foundation point that you were built to
serve
you were built to serve you want to have
an impact
you want to make a difference you want
to wake up every day and feel like the
work that you do matters
and serving people lights up your brain
like food and sex
you have to do it how do you serve
through your pain
the point is to live in the pain the
point is to use that pain
as a conduit to help other people escape
the pain
not to go back and relive it over and
over and over again but to recognize
that that pain
however you suffered whoever might have
caused something to you
was the greatest gift that they could
have given you because now you're gonna
go off
and make sure that millions of people
around the world
don't feel the same way that you felt
you're built to serve humans are built
to serve
period serving others is hardwired into
our brain
it triggers the same area of your brain
as food
and sex if you're not happy it's because
you're not serving
either serving the world on this big
mission that you have or serving the 25
closest people to you if you're not
happy it's because you're not
serving so one of the hacks that i do in
my life to get me to do the things that
i'm afraid of or don't want to do
is through service if i can connect any
of my actions like making videos
i don't necessarily like just sitting
here talking to a camera but i connected
to service
that i'm making this video people are
gonna watch it hopefully they get
inspired enough to take some kind of
action and it's meaningful
to their life or business that makes me
feel good that's service
as soon as i can connect the action to
service
i am all in and that's a way to hack me
you want something for me
whether it's my wife or my team or
general public
if it makes me feel like this will serve
other people and it would have a big
impact
then it's much easier for me to get a
yes it's easy for me to say i am in
and so this is one of the biggest
challenges that i have uh with
dr tess so dr tas is on my other channel
where she's helping me play a bigger
game she's a psychologist
out of australia one of the leading
psychologists in australia and she
coaches
executives and entrepreneurs for
performance
mental performance and she's been
constantly challenging me
to to share vulnerabilities to share
weaknesses to
to talk about when i'm struggling or
when i doubt myself
and she said of course like don't you
doubt yourself like of course all the
time i doubt myself
all the time all the time i'm thinking
about
why am i not further ahead what if this
thing doesn't work
fears and insecurities all day long of
course and so she's like okay you got to
share that
you got to share it but here's the thing
as soon as i get to sharing it
it's service right as soon as i go from
feeling low energy or feeling
afraid of something and then i go to
get my phone out and record a message as
soon as i make the connection that this
is service
i feel great it the the fear the anxiety
the nerves are gone
and so my video ends up being super fed
like hey guys i'm really nervous right
now
you know i gotta go make these videos i
hope they're good it's fake because i'm
i'm in service mode now
and so what i do naturally of turning to
service i think is actually what you
guys should do i think that's actually
the hack i think whenever you are afraid
of doing something
or you've got insecurities or some kind
of weakness some blocked preventing you
from moving forward
turn it into service either serving the
world again big mission
or just it's going to serve somebody
close to you that you know the closest
20 25 people in your life
if you can adjust it in your mindset
that this scary thing this thing that
you don't want to do or
you're afraid of is going to help
somebody
then you're way more likely to do it
that's where i default to
my my challenge is the opposite my
challenge is i want to sit in the
funeral security
long enough to be able to make a message
and then
think about service this is one of the
big things why i
i fail at dr tess's assignments
is because i'm too happy and i don't sit
in pain enough
and that that makes me unrelatable right
because most people sit and wallow in
pain and unhappiness and frustrations
and i don't
because i'll go to service and then i
get happy and so it's a huge hack i
think you should take it on and there's
a three-step process i want to guide you
through that i think will help
step number one is understand how are
you built so i believe that
the people are built in two different
ways some people want to serve the world
right you've got the big mission i want
to help a billion entrepreneurs
i want to solve the world's biggest
problem a lack of belief right this is
what i'm on it's never going to happen
but i wake up every day trying to make
it happen that this is this is
my big mission in life right i want to
serve the world
other people are built to serve the 25
people closest to them
your close friends your family this is
nina my wife
she does not have some giant mission
wanting to save the world
but she's in contact with people from
elementary school in china you know
she stays in touch with people she loves
it and so she's a very
inner circle kind of person so if you're
in her inner circle she's gonna
love you and care for you and support
you and and just help you out so much
but she doesn't have that big mission so
step one is understand how are you built
chances are you're built to go serve the
world because you're watching this
channel
but if you're not or if you're trying to
help somebody else figure out how
they're serving for me to try to
tell nina you have this big mission and
you want to change the world it's never
going to connect because
that's not who she is but if you can
connect it to doing this will help your
family
doing this will help the 25 closest
people to you it'll make a big impact
and make her want to move
step number two is figure out how can
you surf and i'm going to go deeper into
this with my next book
stay tuned january 2020 it's coming but
how can you serve what skills do you
have
what pain did you suffer through then
how can you contribute back and help the
people around
you it's great that you want to serve
you're unhappy because you're not
serving but how can you actually then go
off
and serve somebody and just spending a
little bit time thinking about it
doesn't have to be this week-long
meditation where you're going deep to
figure it out
if that's your style awesome go for it
but even as a challenge today
you could find someone to serve you can
find some way to serve somebody
even if it's a quick five-minute
interaction maybe you see somebody
who's struggling on instagram or twitter
and they're complaining about something
that's happened in their life and
they're they're saying i don't know how
to do this and
you pull out your phone and you make a
quick video message to send it to them
you just helped you just served you feel
great
you know that you helped that person
solve that problem all it takes is a
little bit of conscious focus on it
we're not consciously focusing on who
can we serve
or if we're asking the question well how
can i serve it's it's being asked
with an intonation that is defeating
like well i can't how can i serve
anybody
instead of asking it how can i serve
somebody
if there's hope if you believe that you
can get an answer then you can
and so figuring out how can you actually
serve people in a way
that transfers your skill sets abilities
knowledge hope beliefs
so that they can get a result and you'll
feel great for helping them out
and then step number three is how often
are you serving if you're only serving
and helping people once a month you're
going to feel hollow you're going to
feel empty you're going to feel like you
have no purpose you're going to feel
like
there's more inside you you're not going
to feel complete this is part of what we
need as humans
so i like doing it daily i schedule time
i have a 5s morning routine where i go
through five different
s's where i wake up and i'll do sing
then sun then soar then sweat then scare
but the most important in there is soar
the third one
and it's what's the thing that you need
to do to make you soar so for me it's
sharing so for me
every morning i wake up and i think of
somebody that i helped yesterday and
then i'll record a message
to my instagram for my stories and
what that does is makes me feel like i'm
contributing it makes me
remember that the work i do matters
thinking of somebody that i helped
yesterday
is a reminder that what i do matters i
helped that person yesterday
just one person that's not a billion
it's one person
and then sharing a message i feel like
i'm talking to that person i'll imagine
i'm talking to that person when i'm
making my 15 second video
i'm sharing a message and it's service
because it's going to be helping other
people
if you are not happy in life it's
because you're not serving enough
i believe that humans are good 99.999
of humans are good there's a tiny little
fraction of a percent of people who
enjoy
giving harm and hurting others because
they have some chemical imbalance
but apart from that people are good and
we are connected to each other your
highest purpose in life will come from
helping others
but the next question becomes how how do
i do it how do i find my higher purpose
how do i know what i'm supposed to do
how do i get direction i'm going to give
you the three-step process that i call
the purpose planner
that will give you the clarity that
you're looking for i break it down
into your who your why and your how
let's start with the who
your who is your one word most important
core value everybody has
a core value if you're a human being you
have a core value that you believe in
more than anything else
and when you understand who you are when
you understand your single most
important core value
then you're less likely to be swayed by
other people you're less likely to live
somebody else's version of your life
because they have clarity and you don't
when you do not have clarity you end up
chasing everybody else's clarity you end
up doing
their version because they have
certainty and you have no idea what
you're doing
it's like you're walking on quicksand
and you're constantly sinking and you
know there's something greater for you
your one word your most important core
value is the rock that you stand on
when the rest of the world is crumbling
around you so for me it's belief my one
word is believe
that's what i stand on if you love
believe you're going to be a huge fan of
this channel because i talk about it in
some form
in every video every video should ooze
believe if you hate believe
you're probably gone by now you hate my
channel and that's okay go
go do your thing somewhere else you need
to figure out your who
you need to figure out what your one
word most important core value is that
becomes the lens through which you see
your entire world and attracts the
goodness into your life
step number two is your why why do you
do what you do now i'm a big believer
that your purpose comes from your pain
that whatever your most painful moment
was in life whatever you struggled with
the most
growing up in life whatever moment in
life you felt the most
worthless as a human being your highest
purpose
your greatest joy and satisfaction will
come
from helping people who are currently
feeling the way that you felt
who are currently facing that situation
that you were in
that you hated the thing that you would
never wish upon anybody else in the
world
lots of people are going through that
thing and if you can step in and help
those people
that's going to be so filling up your
soul i can't even explain it to you
for me my one word is believe that's my
who my why is i struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
i hated my life i i was struggling was
making 300 a month i felt
worthless as a human i felt like i was
bringing no value to the world
and that was massively frustrating i
felt alone and i didn't know what to do
that's why i love helping entrepreneurs
i love believing in entrepreneurs why
entrepreneurs could be anybody i could
believe in anybody
believe is at the core of who i am is my
one word most important core value but i
could be believe it in anybody and i do
and i love it but entrepreneurs
hold that special spot for me and the
startup entrepreneurs
not the ones who are already making tons
of money i love them too
but i resonate so much more with the
startup entrepreneurs because i remember
what it's like
eating at mcdonald's and only being able
to afford french fries instead of an
entire meal
so your why your purpose comes from your
pain figure out what that most painful
moment was for you
and it's hard because entrepreneurs we
like looking and being optimistic and
looking forward and being positive but
it's in that pain that your answer
actually is
find out what that most painful moment
was your why your highest purpose will
come
from helping people who are currently
facing that right now and then step
three is the how
so how are you gonna do it there's a lot
of ways you can help people who are in
that situation
so for me break it down the who is my
one word it's
believe the why is helping entrepreneurs
purpose comes from my pain now how do i
help entrepreneurs how do i believe in
entrepreneurs
there's a ton of ways that i could be
believing in entrepreneurs
so the example you use if is if you are
moving your office and you need my help
to rent a moving truck and to help you
carry your desks and
all of that stuff i love the end result
of it i love that now you have this
great office where you can build a
business and have it flourish
and i'll probably say yes to helping you
do that especially if you're a close
friend
but i don't love the process of moving
i don't love the process of packing up
boxes i don't love the process of
setting up cables and wires and
putting together an office i don't love
that process i love the result
because i'm believing in entrepreneurs
but i don't want the process and so if
you write down you make a list of all
the things that you do the activities
that you have done
that you've enjoyed the result make a
list of 10 to 15 times you've helped
somebody
with that same pain that you had growing
up you've helped them
and you enjoyed the end result and then
circle the ones where you enjoyed the
process as well
because when you can enjoy the process
and you enjoy the end result
it's a home run now you've found your
higher purpose now you have clarity
now you have a plan that's the point of
the purpose planner
step one you figure out your who your
one word most important core value
step two you figure out your why your
purpose comes from your pain the thing
that you never want anybody to ever have
to experience again because it was so
painful for you
and then step three is the how the
process you need to love the process you
figure out those three things
you are set for life if you want to sign
up for the entire billionaire mindset
series for free and get the companion
bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there